foreign  [Music]  we're extremely sad to have missed d23  but we've been working very hard on the  next Deadpool film for uh a good long  while now I've had to really search my  soul on this one his first appearance in  the MCU obviously needs to feel special  we need to stay true to the character uh  finding depth motivation new meaning  every Deadpool needs to stand out and  stand apart it's been an incredible  challenge that has forced me to reach  down deep inside and I  have nothing  yeah just completely  empty up here  and terrifying but we did have one idea  hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one  more time  yeah sure  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]